الدكتور مصطفى باقيي هو رئيس
المبادرة الوطنية الفلسطينية
وعضو في البرلمان الفلسطيني، وهو
ينضم إلي الآن على الهواء مباشرة من مدينة رالا بالضفة الغربية.
دكتور بوي، من الجيد رؤيتك،
شكرًا لك، شكرًا لاستضافتي، حتى
تعرف بوضوح كل شيء.  تتجه الأنظار إلى غزة
الآن وهذه العملية العسكرية الإسرائيلية
وإلى أين ستصل، لكن كما تعلمون
في الصورة الكبيرة، فإن إحدى أكبر
العقبات التي تعترض السلام بين الإسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين كانت دائمًا
أن المتطرفين من كلا الجانبين
تمكنوا من تحديد كيفية حدوث ذلك.  الصراع
يتطور ويبدو الآن أننا
نرى ذلك
كبيرًا تمامًا كما قلت كنا
نعيش تحت ضغط التطرف
هنا أه لقد ذكرت حماس لكن
من الجيد أن نذكر أن أه إسرائيل كانت
تدار من قبل حكومة متطرفة للغاية
ومنهم سموتريش الذي أعلن أن
الفلسطينيين يجب ألا يكون لديهم أمل في أي
دولة وأه عليهم إما
الهجرة أو القبول بحياة
القهر أو الموت أه هذا التطرف
بالطبع أدى إلى هذا الانفجار ولكن
السبب الجذري الرئيسي الذي لم يتم
التعامل معه من قبل عدة
حكومات إسرائيلية  هو استمرار
الاحتلال الإسرائيلي غير القانوني
للأراضي الفلسطينية، وحقيقة أن هذا
الاحتلال الذي يبلغ من العمر 56 عامًا هو
الأطول في التاريخ الحديث قد
تحول إلى نظام أبارتي
يقمع كل فلسطيني اليوم
بالطبع القضية ليست أن إسرائيل
تهاجم حماس فقط  الغارات الجوية الإسرائيلية والقصف
الإسرائيلي
يهاجمان السكان الفلسطينيين المدنيين
في غزة، إنهم يجردون
حماس من إنسانيتهم، لكنهم في هذه العملية
يجردون جميع الفلسطينيين من إنسانيتهم، وعندما
تهاجم مكانًا يعد أكبر
سجن مفتوح في العالم يضم 2.2
مليون شخص ويعيشون  في أقل من
أه
1140 ميلاً مربعاً 50% من
السكان البالغ عددهم 2.2 مليون هم أطفال أطفال
والنتيجة قاسية أعني حتى الآن
1200 فلسطيني قتلوا في
الغارات الجوية الإسرائيلية بما في ذلك 326
طفلاً وأه ما لا يقل عن 180 امرأة
هذا لن  يؤدي إلى السلام أه
المخرج من هذا هو وقف
إطلاق النار فورًا ووقف التصعيد
فورًا وتبادل الأسرى
حتى يعود هؤلاء الإسرائيليون الذين ينجزون
غزة إلى ديارهم آمنين
مقابل إطلاق سراح بعض
السجناء الفلسطينيين الذين كانوا في
السجون في بعض الأحيان  منهم في السجن منذ
43 عامًا لا أحد يتحدث عن وقف إطلاق النار
في هذه المرحلة لا أحد يتحدث
بجدية عن تبادل الأسرى في
الوقت الحالي أه وهذا أمر مؤسف
وهذا سوف يحدث لأن هذا سوف يؤدي إلى
شيء واحد أعتقد أنه مهم
نذكر هنا أنك تعلم أن
المجموعة المسلحة التي تسيطر على غزة
ليست صديقة للسلطة الفلسطينية.
غالبًا ما اشتبك الحزب السياسي المستقبلي لمحمود عباس
مع حماس. ما مدى قلقك
الآن من هذا التدفق من
التعاطف والخروج من أجل  إسرائيل وهذا
التدفق من الإدانة لما
فعلته حماس والذي كان بمثابة نبأ مفاده أن
الفلسطينيين الآن يتم اكتساحهم جميعًا بشكل أساسي
على أنهم حماس
ومكانتك التي بذل فيها العديد من الفلسطينيين
جهدًا كبيرًا، لقد
عمل هانا شاري ساروت بجهد لا يصدق
لتأسيس الفلسطينيين كفلسطينيين.
دولة بديلة ذات مصداقية وقابلة للحياة والتي
يتم جرفها الآن بوحشية
نهاية الأسبوع لا ينبغي أن تكون
وأه مجرد إرسال
دعاية إسرائيلية بعضها غير
صحيح على الإطلاق لن يحل المشكلة
وتجريد جميع الفلسطينيين من إنسانيتهم
لن يحل المشكلة أيضًا انظر  لقد
كنا تحت الاحتلال لسنوات عديدة
ولم نشهد يومًا من الحرية منذ 56
عامًا والكثير منا وخاصة 70٪
من سكان غزة هم لاجئون
شردتهم إسرائيل أه قبل 75 عامًا
فإسرائيل بالفعل  شنت خمس
حروب على غزة هل أنهت ذلك، حماس فعلت ذلك
وأنهت العنف فعلت ذلك أنهت الوضع
بالطبع لا، وعندما يخططون
الآن لعملية برية ضخمة فإنهم
ينخرطون في شيء
غير إنساني على الإطلاق وغير مقبول حتى وفقًا لما
يقوله الأمين العام للأمم المتحدة.
الأمم المتحدة التي قالت لا يمكنك فرض
حصار كامل على غزة الآن، إسرائيل
تمنع الطعام والحليب والماء والكهرباء
عن سكان غزة. أتلقى مكالمات
أنا طبيب وأتلقى مكالمات
كل يوم من مرضى في غزة على
وشك الموت بسبب ذلك.  ليس لديهم إمكانية
الوصول إلى غسيل الكلى والأطفال
والحاضنات الذين يمكن أن يموتوا لأنه
لا يوجد كهرباء، إن حصار
السكان بأكمله ليس حلاً،
وضرب الأطفال والنساء بغارة
جوية رهيبة ليس حلاً
واسمحوا لي أن أحذركم بشدة.
الخطر المهم هنا هو ما
يدعو إليه القادة الإسرائيليون وهو
إجلاء 2.2 مليون شخص في غزة
إلى مصر، مما يخلق مسألة خطيرة للغاية تتمثل في
التطهير العرقي مرة أخرى
ضد الشعب الفلسطيني، وهذا لن
يؤدي إلى السلام، وهذا لن يؤدي إلى السلام.  إلى
السلام حتى لو كانت الولايات المتحدة
تدعم إسرائيل بشكل كامل، فإن الشيء الوحيد الذي
يؤدي إلى السلام الدائم سيكون
التسوية عن طريق التفاوض،
وهكذا، ولكن من الذي منع المفاوضات هو
الذي منع المفاوضات طوال هذه السنوات كان
نتنياهو نتنياهو هو الذي أثار غضب
الجمهور الإسرائيلي ضد إيتاك رين لأنه  لقد
وقع على اتفاق سلام مع
الفلسطينيين وتم اغتيال رابين على
يد متطرف إسرائيلي ثم قام
نتنياهو بمنع جميع المفاوضات مع
الفلسطينيين. أريد فقط أن
أنهي نوعًا ما ربما بملاحظة إيجابية
هنا لأن حل الدولتين
كان في المؤخرة  ثم
يبدو التجميد العميق على أجهزة دعم الحياة الآن
ذكرى بعيدة تقريبًا، دائمًا ما تكون
أحلك قبل الفجر، هل أنت على الأقل
متفائل بأنه ربما بمجرد انتهاء
الأسوأ، سيكون هناك
إدراك أنه لا يمكن أن يكون هناك
سلام دائم إلا من خلال التفاوض
التسوية بين الفلسطينيين
والإسرائيليين بالتأكيد، وعلى الرغم من أن الأمر
قد يبدو غريبًا في هذا الوقت، دعني
أخبرك أننا ناضلنا بشدة طوال
حياتنا من أجل التوصل إلى حل الدولتين،
لكن لسوء الحظ بذل نتنياهو قصارى جهده
لقتل هذا الحل من خلال الاستيطان عن طريق إرسال المستوطنين.
إلى الأراضي الفلسطينية المحتلة
بشكل غير قانوني أه أقول
وقد يبدو هذا غريبا الآن ولكن
أقول إن الطريق الوحيد للخروج من هذا هو إما
حل الدولتين الفوري أو
سنضطر إلى التبادل سيتعين علينا تغيير
واقع دولة الفصل العنصري الواحدة التي
قامت بها إسرائيل  تم إنشاؤها لأنها
واقع دولة واحدة منفصلة مع
واقع دولة ديمقراطية أه واحدة لا توجد طريقة
ليتخلى الفلسطينيون عن
نضالهم من أجل الحرية ولا توجد طريقة
أعرفها لمواصلة هذا
الوضع اللاإنساني إما أن يكون لدينا
حل الدولتين في أقرب وقت  ممكن أو سيتعين علينا أن
نكون معًا على قدم المساواة ولكن يجب
معاملة الفلسطينيين على قدم المساواة
وهذا يعني الحقوق المدنية والوطنية الديمقراطية الكاملة
لكلا الشعبين دكتور باقي،
شكرًا لك على وجودك معنا، وقتك ثمين
للغاية وهو محل تقدير كبير، شكرًا لك سيدي،
شكرًا
لك.